thank you
[Music]
welcome back to a very special careful
boys where we are very careful boys
what's up today we have an a question is
cheating a deal breaker no matter what
Oh you mean like cheating well in your
in the relationship in your relationship
I think it depends on so many different
factors because for some it's like part
like boom yeah yeah
like how many years you've been together
how old you are you have kids together
yeah do you have kids how fresh is the
relationship you know we're talking
about strictly sex or is it like
emotional cheese what's cheating you
that's true that's true well I just I
just know that there have been
completely different conversations right
whatever you said has cheating again
yeah yeah and if that happens you know
what's funny Hannah Hannah said that
um she's like if you do cheat she goes I
think you're gonna cheat accidentally
and I'm like how do you accidentally
[__] with someone and she's like no I
think you're gonna have a girlfriend
accidentally like you're gonna get into
a relationship like you're gonna put a
ring on it accidentally and I'm like how
do how does one get into it accidentally
you know it's kind of like how you
always end up with [__] up your ass you
know she's like you always like falling
on your child what's going on
flashlights and stuff so she's like so
she's like no no she goes like prom
photo because you're very friendly so
you're gonna just talk to a bunch of
people and then before you know it
you're gonna be in a relationship with
the girl because you're enjoying that
conversation but you don't talk like
that but who knows she goes you're gonna
you might have attraction that that's
gonna and for like it's like one of
those things where like I might be
friend zoning them but they're on to me
and then just sucking oh so you won't
know that you're like leading a girl on
yeah because we're just having a blast
okay guys like peoples or whatever right
and then yeah like she's sucking my dick
and I can't resist and I'm like I guess
I got a girlfriend now so but then stuff
she's saying if she knows it's
accidental already isn't it okay it was
an accident I guess so maybe that's got
your back kind of saying like you can't
[__] other girls if you want because I
know you're an idiot and you'll have an
accident God is that kind of like a
light Hall Pass I don't think so it was
a different the context was different
but it sounds like low expectations
I think she was just saying you're an
impulsive idiot but it sounded like
you're just you're so naive that you
would accidentally get into a situation
that you can't get out of yeah because
it wasn't intentional and I'm like okay
okay I I really do see that because I
don't ever think about like cheating on
her you guys are unique
yeah yeah meant to be you're like oh oh
I'm sleeping with a girl and I'm like
that felt real good but I think that was
a big mistake like she's not even like
you're gonna accidentally cheat it's
like you're gonna accidentally be in a
relationship with another human being
for a long time
long-term relationship yeah and I'm
clueless about it like hey we're just
friends we're [__] but we're friends
yeah I mean that's very hard to do
considering you you talk about Hannah
like pretty often so a girl would have
to have a game dude that's game it's
this on-camera live present yeah yeah I
wonder how many other things she thinks
she'll accidentally do like accidentally
buy a car sign a like seven year the
lease to somewhere like what other apps
you guys gotta ask maybe you gotta ask
her because I try to fir I try to
understand it because I'm like how do
you accidentally get into a cheating
situation but it made sense after she
just explained it yeah maybe because
it's like she goes yeah you'll know that
you're like in love but you'll
accidentally fall in love because you
didn't create barriers to be careful
you're just like in the moment having a
blast I can understand that being like
needing to be risk-averse because nobody
or I don't want to say nobody but it's
not like people who like uh find
themselves in cheating situations are
like I'm gonna go cheat today you know
what I'm saying they but they just don't
make the right risk-averse choices yeah
they haven't put the precautions yeah
now they're in a circumstance yeah it's
like Congressman Anthony Weiner is what
you're saying yeah yeah he's like too
close how am I on this with the phone
with a 16 year old girl sitting on my
dick this is weird because I can't
believe it what am I doing how the heck
am I
what an accident I know what you're
saying Anthony oh there's foot sprays in
my [__] how did it happen
watch this video for reference that's
not linked yeah do you think that
happens whatever parameters you set with
Nina about what cheating is is it a deal
breaker for you
like if she were to do it if she were to
do the thing that you said cheating is
yeah
and she's sorry
I mean short answer yes long answer I
think context comes into like so much
you know what I mean yeah like I I think
so short answer you would forgive her no
short answer it is cheating short answer
it's like it's a deal breaker you know
what I mean but like long answer like
the circumstance the context like was I
doing something that [__] up for like
like the last year and I was was I
pushing you know what I mean like I I
think that there might just be I think
the answer is it's wrong to do it
absolutely I think that's like a a very
like having been through and lots of
experience type of answer but in your
younger because I feel like you know
when you're younger things are way more
black and white oh dude yeah I think I
think when um I was younger I had way
more um absolutes yeah yeah yeah yeah
and the reason why I had more absolutes
is because it was so much more simple
like you didn't have a whole entire like
life and career maybe with your partner
you know what my deal breaker was like
can like maybe early High School it was
like if you cheat on me we're breaking
up if you don't give [__] or Break
It
was like
I was like those deal breakers you guys
don't leave me hanging
it's funny because it's you know what I
mean stand up
when you're a 17 year old boy and you
find out she doesn't give head you're
like what because if you cheat on me you
don't love me if you don't blow me you
don't love me either yeah yeah for real
wow that's that's real [__] affection
bro
I mean it's kind of a good absolute you
know what I mean at that age it's
acceptable not even that age I was like
20 [__] four and I was dating this
girl who like told me she doesn't get
blow jobs and I started cheating on her
immediately with my ex I'm not kidding
I fully got that guy
he's like you [__] cheers I fully got
a blowy oh wait I'm a cheater now
Advanced experience
it's so funny because that's really like
one of the biggest goals of guys is like
is like sexual things yeah yeah when
you're young it's like you just want to
know what everything's like yeah I want
to know what the inside of your mouth
like your mouth because that's the peak
of it all right like you're not thinking
about building a family you're not
thinking about all the adult [__] you're
just thinking about she looks good and I
want to feel her short-term or release
and skills it's skill development B and
B dude I don't even that's a long term
for me yeah
you know what's also really [__] up
um you're like uh discovering your own
ego at that age too oh yeah so like when
you you didn't know you could get some
right and then you get some and then
you're like the second somebody else may
be hotter or whatever that you knew was
out of your league suddenly shows
interest you're like oh you didn't know
that you could even get into that place
of interest and you you kind of start
climbing this weird Eagle ladder but you
don't you don't know that it's like this
is my ego you're just like I didn't even
know your ego won't admit it's the ego I
was climbing that thing one the back of
one neck at a time dude like stairs damn
stepping on the back of one next step
one on the back of another neck next to
the top huh you're just pinning chicks
down stepping on their [__] heads and
just doing your thing
[Laughter]
I know something kind of weird too is
that like so when we're young we have
these natural absolutes and it's it
feels so strong to be like no I don't
care it's gonna be this and like of
course I had those growing up and then
as I'm maturing I'm starting to get more
like leeway and be less absolute but at
the same time it backfired because when
you're not as absolute in One Direction
you're also not absolute in the other
and I ended up having the problem of
girls I dated feeling like I also could
leave at any moment
whoa and because they they they thought
it was too indifferent yeah because you
didn't care enough yeah because they're
like oh wow like I grew into this space
of like no I think if no matter what
happens like it's open for discussion
like I'm not absolutely Gonna Leave You
but they wanted something and I'm also
not jealousy stay right because they
almost feel like it's either both sides
of commitment you're either commit or
you're not coming what is it but it's
like but it means so much though so
transitioning away from like the young
mentality of like absolutes if you skip
that part and you just get rid of the
attitude as a whole you're gonna lose
both ends so it's more like oh let's
just fix one side through experience and
then not necessarily do this you know
it's hard to remember that yeah yeah
it's not easy to be dumb around you is
it no because I want to just take a
stand and just like make a hot take and
then you're gonna bring all this Nuance
I'm like oh [__] yeah I didn't think
about it that way too much critical
thinking [__] that [__] it's easy to
look why are you so thoughtful dude
because everyone hey
um eye-opening moments was uh like my
parents obviously got divorced when I
was like six so I never really had that
like
wholesome a couple role model or like
how people show affection and
affectionate not people like they they
they usually have some sort of role
model that they naturally like okay
that's what love is or whatever that was
it for my grandparents that was my my uh
my mom's side where every time I went
back to Taiwan like they're like the
cutest little couple and they would like
take walks in the park and you would see
like my grandma holding my grandpa and
like looking at birds and talking and
like the way my grandpa like uh was such
a gentleman was my grandma like I was
just like oh [__] I think that's like
how it's supposed to be and it's very
like almost Disney and chivalrous and I
was like I'm a spider to be that and
then so I thought they were the perfect
couple then when my grandma got
Alzheimer's she started saying crazy
[__] because
um and Things From the Past would come
out and then so she would just like
randomly come out of her bedroom and be
like yes
and all my grandpa was trying to do was
like hey
my grandma would have an episode you
didn't [__] me enough and then one of
the times like you [__] cheated on me
oh my God damn
[Music]
my grandpa did work on a boat and she
would go off to like she was a player
sea man yeah and he was like you weren't
on those [__] boats yet and I was
like oh [__] and I think I was maybe
like late teens early 20s but then you
start to see like what was so beautiful
like what it took I guess to become such
a beautiful picture and how everything
is oh isn't always like what it seems
and people have their own struggles and
yeah I don't put things on a pedestal
because who knows what the real story
was like Will and Jada exactly I was
like that I do a couple crazy dude damn
yeah I just think for me trust is just
so [__] wild like trust is the base
layer to any relationship and if I lose
that it's done like I can't get that
back I feel like that's how I am that's
the fire gone poof and I'm like oh I
gotta I can't I can't be here anymore
because I think the reason why somebody
would cheat or something like that would
be understandable and you could take
fault and be like yeah for sure but you
still went out of your way to hide and
and not be truthful so like at a certain
point in time it's hard for at least for
me to be like I I can't ignore that no
like I kind of look at people
differently like I respect I've had
friends who like cheated on their girls
and then I'd be like bro I can't even
look at you the same same bro like to
the poor to the point high-fiving them
it's like yeah yeah you're talking about
yeah I never talked to him again I I
distance myself and just like I mean
like I said the the wife probably thinks
I'm the biggest [__] ever because
there's ghosted them but I didn't know
what else to do I couldn't be a liar to
her yeah because she was my friend too
yeah guilty like a like a cooperator
yeah and I was I was a total accomplice
like he was doing it in my place and I
was like what the [__] do I do yeah it
was like you're an accomplished yeah but
I didn't I thought it was a bit like I
thought it was a bit like the way he
talked about it I saw it crazy this dude
was just gonna bring a chick over from
Craigslist I was like yeah of course you
are that's funny because he would do
those lines with his wife in the room
all the [__] time yeah they were real
yeah he's a guilty he's [__] saying
it out loud constantly just like taking
some of the pressure out or whatever but
yeah I couldn't deal with it wow
sometimes when we're watching movies or
like TV shows and I'm watching with my
girl she's always like and if like the
character is like cheating or doing
something sneaky she was like if you
ever do some [__] like that and you'll
find out what happens
she just always says that but it's like
she's like it's like a we do it's like I
get threatened all the time too it's
dancer that's a live side sexy to hear
sometimes it is she's right and you keep
[__] around
you you ever do some [__] like that
you're gonna see what happens to your
sleep trying to find out she's like
she's like I'm gonna get you I never
even see you [__] around nah bro I've
seen you [__] around I [__] around
with boys hey low-key low-key there was
a there's a point in time oh this is
gonna sound super susque so the kids
would say but yeah there's a certain
point inside yeah there's a certain
point time where Tiff was actually
worried that like I would cheat on her
with a dude
she's like I see you spending all those
hours at Jiu Jitsu rolling around with
men
nah
I was like for real that was crazy she
thought you were a gay boy Nick's like
for real I know how'd you know that that
was uh like sort of likely you step on
that neck step on that neck give me a
little bit step
you're gonna cheat with a man it was
more of like a bit more than anything it
was like an ongoing Oh I thought it was
real what I wish it was real it was it
was like serious enough where at certain
points I didn't know if she was serious
or not you know she was on to you and
she's [__]
I was playing mind games with you yeah
yeah exactly like they have an Alabama
straight back and only use it once yeah
she's good at that
happen bro there's a ghost in this
[__] [__] bottle just [__] went
down by itself and it spinning
I saw a movement but I don't know where
did you bump the table bro I saw a
replay on the live it's it just fell on
its own you bumped the table down there
I did yeah the energy is too good ghost
of [__] water bottle because the Kiev
dude
but yeah tip always gives me reminders
she goes in your sleep she's like I'm
gonna get you in your sleep if you keep
[__] I was like yeah she counted and
you should say you're accidental let me
ask you this is the the history of
cheating affect you
your trust currently it's hard to ignore
maybe like let's say you never knew a
story that your girl told you and she
just goes like oh yeah I cheated on like
three exes oh yeah that would be
interesting but former relationship yeah
yeah does that affect today's trust nah
I think a giant bomb secret like you
might be like whoa but you know a
[__] I knew from a jump when you were
young and it's something that wasn't a
bomb but it was like oh that was a poor
choice uh-huh I don't think it's good
like if she cheated on her ex with her
ex's brother
that's kind of a bomb
dude I did I don't so I had a similar
thing with Nikki like straight man wise
Nikki was straight man to me because I
told her all the stories about me
getting revenge on like on like people
who wronged me like my ex-friend and
[__] like that yeah people who have
wronged yeah how dare they how dare they
exactly just make a whole list like the
hardcore Revenge though right so um she
actually like was pretty
um in the early early months of our
relationship she was like she's like you
know there is a part of me that just
thinks like are you getting revenge on
your ex because she really didn't want
you to to hook up with me
you know like yeah yeah yeah I don't
think she really like a phantom
motivation yeah but she played it
straight enough like for a couple for a
couple weeks that you had to address it
yeah I was like wait is this real hey
what's going on here and then yeah so no
it's all good she played it straight for
weeks yeah well she kept she kept
hitting me with like a little bit about
it like little playful pokes you know
and I was like but it's not my game for
you because you're like wait do you
really think that though yeah exactly
because you're like whoa I really love
you though this is crazy like no no it's
not like that but like our relationship
was so hot and heavy and so quick like
it was like I was already like inside
making like nine days later let's go
let's go
[Applause]
JK was [__] crazy like I could see it
from the side and in the bottle just
fall by itself it's because he hit the
table he said no dude
it just went like this it felt slow
motion though it's still slow motion
look it felt slow motion that was so
weird I couldn't do it again that one's
almost falling over thank you guys for
joining us thank you for joining us
[Applause]
bye-bye everything
[Music]